gonna be honest with you I was gonna get
a haircut this morning and then I woke
up to the fact that there is an amazing
spider-man 2 trailer so we're gonna talk
about that first
it's a Spider Man it's my boy so this
trailer for the amazing spider-man 2
looks pretty cool spider-man is doing
his spider manage stuff you see his new
suit his new suit looks really cool
honest corpses big evil corporation we
already knew that but now Dane DeHaan is
Harry Osborn and looks cool because
Dane DeHaan is an awesome actor there
yeah husband you're gonna want to see
this Oscar and you under surveillance
why isn't that question of not sure
about the emo over though I don't
remember hurry I was born having that
haircut it's just a haircut though Joker
didn't have long nappy hair the hair
does not make the man friends the man
makes the hair you remember that when
you look at this when I hear Dane
DeHaan was gonna be Harry Osborn I was
like cool I can just channel Dane DeHaan
from Chronicle and I think he'll kill it
in this role and he's not just Harry
Osborn my friends freeze the Green
Goblin
I saw the banner and I was like you said
jeez I painted on a green goblin which
got me excited and admittedly a little
scared my thing about this new amazing
spider-man movie franchises it almost
felt like up to this point that they
didn't want to rehash villains they'd
already donnelly alright we're gonna
have electro Rhino lizard because those
weren't in the Sam Raimi spider-man
movies I was just like dude bring in the
Green Goblin and now it looks like we
get the Green Goblin but I was like I
meant bring in the Green Goblin if it
doesn't mean there are gonna be three
villains in this movie just looking a
little overcrowded friends I still
optimistic about the movie cuz it looks
really cool I'm just saying we've had a
Spider Man movie with three films before
it was terrible and yeah granted the
fact that there were three villains in
spider-man 3 wasn't the only thing wrong
with it but it was like the fifth thing
that was wrong with it it was definitely
a problem in the movie so when I see
overcrowding in spider-man movie I start
to get scared
it looks like Dane DeHaan face is the
Goblin like his face is messed up and it
kind of looks like a goblin which I will
take that over the Sam Raimi spider-man
movie that just had a metal Goblin mask
whose mouth didn't move it always bugged
me Willem Dafoe killed it as Norman
Osborn I love that dude as Norman Osborn
but the goblins face didn't move when he
talked and you can see Willem Dafoe's
mouth inside the goblins mouth talking
and I was like that looks like cheap
Halloween so given the choice
of the - I liked the goblins face whose
faces of Goblin and you're not gonna
have really good prosthetics cuz i
really doubt Osborn is gonna sit there
and his makeup mirror for seven hours
like a movie later I'm gonna go cause
some crime and murder and it would
make sense that his face would just look
like a goblin however chronological
a little weird cuz norman osborn was a
goblin before harry osborn I didn't get
a good look at the Goblin in this movie
I'm pretty sure it's Dane DeHaan though
it's the fact that Norman Osborn's in
bed looking like he has leprosy or
something what about Peter not everyone
has a happy end here's another thing
about Norman Osborn you remember at the
end of the amazing spider-man lizards in
his cell and that dude comes to him with
the coat and he's all creepy I was like
is that Norman Osborn but I'm pretty
sure in this trailer you see that same
silhouetted figure so I was like is that
probably not cuz Norman Osborn like I
said is laying in bed like he has
African Motaba from outbreak or some
so I don't know these are questions
but it's good to have questions after a
trailer it shows entry against what
trailers are for give you questions keep
you intrigued however did you guys see
that check that out again Doc Ock arms
vulture wings is a visual guys Oscorp is
behind everything sinister six movie Oh
Avengers happens oh maybe and we have
electro electro looks badass to this
scene at the end of the trailer just
puts everything in perspective with
electro he's like arcing and fighting
spider-man is pretty badass looking it
is this
how does that not look awesome and we
have the Rhino
kind of the Rhino as I knew and
remembered him is he has this armor
that's like skin ish armor that's
grafted to his body he can't remove it
which I was like that's a cool
technology to explore in this movie
because oscorp's all about technology
it's advancing technology and it's using
people as guinea pigs and it makes sense
no we have Rhino Tron over here and it
looks a little strange can you just see
this we need Rhino sword power no
don't Anton Anton I feel like I'm gonna
walk out of the amazing spider-man to be
like electro green goblin those were
cool but Rhino doesn't have to be in
there so that kind of confuses me it
makes me look at the movie be like hope
you guys know what you're doing and the
end the amazing spider-man 2 does look
really cool electro looks cool green
goblin looks cool Dane DeHaan is a good
actor I like Andrew Garfield as Peter
Parker right now Thunder Zord will see
Paul Giamatti is a good actor though so
we have that working with the right now
I'm looking forward to this movie it
looks exciting it's looking cool which
is the amazing spider-man 2 have you
seen the trailer what do you think about
it whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more I
believe I can fly I believe I can touch
the sky oh cool spider-man
[Music]
you